Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
are now at War and it is getting
delightfully ugly and we should all
cheer this on because the more fractured
that Mega trumpism is the worse it is
for the Republican Party HuffPost
reporting Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert get personal in a very
public spat the extremist congresswoman
from Georgia accused her Colorado
counterpart of quote High School drama
writes Josephine Harvey for HuffPost
what is this all about this started
because bobert criticized green at the
America Fest event
for backing House minority leader Kevin
McCarthy for speaker this I believe is
the moment that started this hilarious
fight someone who we all respect
Marjorie Taylor green says Kevin
McCarthy is going to be a great speaker
I I guess you'll have to ask Marjorie
about that I'm a fan of hers I'm an
admirer but it's not something we see
the same Lauren well you know I I've
been aligned with Marjorie and accused
of believing a lot of the things that
she believes in I don't believe in this
just like um I don't believe in Russian
space places are you a hard no space
lasers and all of this no I'm just
saying we need to actually have an
inside conversation and and make sure
that these promises are there wow
so subsequent to this Marjorie Taylor
green took to Twitter to respond where
she put out a three-tweet screed
starting with quote I've supported and
donated to Lauren bobert
president Trump has supported and
donated to Lauren bobert Kevin McCarthy
has supported and donated to Lauren
bobert she just barely came through by
500 votes so the argument there is
despite all of our powerful support she
barely won
second
quote she gladly takes our money but
when she's been asked Lauren refuses to
endorse president Trump she refuses to
support Kevin McCarthy and she
childishly threw me under the bus for a
cheap sound bite Marjorie Taylor green
continuing quote the country is facing
extremely difficult times
Americans expect conservative Fighters
like us to work together to save America
and that is the only Mission I'm 100
percent devoted to not High School drama
and media sound bites save America
defeat the Democrats
um this is super interesting because
we've known about the wings of the
Republican Party the pro-trump and the
anti-trump wing we know about how Mitt
Romney and Adam kinzinger and Liz Cheney
are in a different wing of the
Republican party than the Maga people
these are all Maga people this is now a
subsequent division within Maga trumpism
where you have the pro Kevin McCarthy
people and the anti-keven McCarthy
people there are a bunch of different
reasons for this one of those reasons
has been McCarthy's
less than total enthusiasm for some of
the tactics
that Trump wanted to use to try to steal
an election he didn't win in 2020. so
this is a division we should absolutely
be encouraging this can only be bad for
Trump and for Republicans as the 2024
primary gets going green and bobert two
of the most visible prominent newish
trumpist figures and for them to be
going at it is extraordinarily
interesting and potentially beneficial
to the left let's face it the holiday
season can be a stressful time for
anyone even a stressor on relationships
in-laws dividing time mismatched
expectations around gifts our sponsor
paired is the app that makes it easy to
maintain a feeling of connection with
your partner during this crazy time of
year you and your partner download the
app you pair together an everyday paired
gives the two of you questions or
quizzes games to have fun stay
emotionally connected deepen your
conversations and all of the exercises
were developed by academics
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and parrot
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below